[Music]
[Music]
it's been a while since we've seen any
major update to the division story but
we've been assured a number of times
that there is something coming what and
how big this will be only the developers
know at this stage
anyone following me for a while will
know that i like to ponder these things
so if you're willing to humor me for the
next few minutes i'm going to run
through a few scenarios of where the
story could be taking us next
starting from the most out there idea
leading down towards the more likely
direction we could see
i must note that these are purely
speculation based on what we've seen
from the narrative direction so far
mixed in with a good amount of my own
over-ambitious imagination
i need to remind everyone that i have
absolutely no collaboration with the
studio working on future content or any
of the developers involved
or do i
no no i really don't i should know
better than to start these sort of
rumors people get very excited
before i get into it let's briefly
summarize where the story is left off
aaron keener is dead
keena's known sales of rogue agents are
also dead
the btsu leader baden schaefer has been
captured by the shd
we've now heard from the leader of the
black tusk natalia sokolova and that
they had a hunter working with them
new york's most senior agent feylau went
rogue joining the black tusk
she then killed president ellis and
blamed it on the division
faye was then killed by the division
probably
maybe
i haven't exactly been quiet about my
disappointment regarding the direction
aaron keena's story took in the division
two
in the first game he was a highly
intelligent mastermind who after feeling
betrayed by the government was always
several steps ahead of the shd
meticulously planning out every step of
the way towards bringing down what he
saw as widely spread corruption within
the government
in the division two it was almost like
he'd lost his mind
he came off as more of a cheesy bond
villain with an over-the-top ludicrous
plan that really made no sense and
certainly didn't mesh well with his
previously established character
maybe it was a case of the villain of
the story starting to be sympathized
with which may have not been quite the
direction the writers wanted it to go i
know i was certainly on team kina
while the division may not have been
written by the man himself the narrative
direction was certainly heavily
influenced by the tom clancy style and
the kina we met in the division 2 was
actually more in line with how clancy
has approached villains in the past
in the cutscene where kina dies we can
see the player agent in kalsa who was
talking to him trying to understand what
he'd just done with his watch when
suddenly isaac announces rogue agent
deceased
the agents then leave the scene without
so much as even checking his pulse
while i struggle to believe that what we
saw in that cutscene was everything that
had happened that kena's body was just
left as is
that a character of his importance
wouldn't have just been extracted by the
jtf later on to be examined
it certainly wouldn't be the first time
that a villain has been brought back
from the dead
hornet is the most obvious example of
this
but hornet was a minor character at this
stage and him suddenly being alive
didn't really have that much impact on
the story
a major character like keener coming
back from the dead
just seems a little bit comic book and
overused
however i can see both sides of this
argument
we're definitely supposed to believe
that he's dead
but there are a few pieces to the story
that could explain how he could still be
alive that actually isn't too
unrealistic regarding the narrative
direction
the first question do we know that we
actually killed keener in the first
place
we certainly killed someone
someone who sounded like kina
someone who we assume looked like kina
i'm not going to go down the path of
body doubles or surgical manipulation or
anything but there is the possibility
that the man who died on the dock wasn't
actually the man himself
i mean our agents have never actually
met kina face to face
agents that had either joined him or
were killed we've only heard from
through recordings and grainy videos and
echoes which to be fair he looked quite
different in a number of them
however before i get too crazy with all
this and start digging down into
conspiracy theories let's jump back into
the story
before we landed on liberty island we
confronted kina's rogue agents one of
them being theo parnell
theo was a tech genius and while we were
actively hunting him down he proved time
and time again that isaac couldn't be
trusted he showed how easy it was to
manipulate the ai into doing reporting
and saying whatever he wanted it to
this is a big part of how theo's special
tech the decoy works
following on from theo's death kina or
whoever we were fighting showed again
how easy it was to control isaac by
having it relay anything he wanted it to
straight into our earpieces
it's entirely possible that theo and
kina had orchestrated the whole plan
that we the agents were meant to catch
up with keener on the island and take
him down or at least think we had
so what was the point in faking his
death
to buy himself some time
similar to what he did on the west side
piers to create a distraction while he
continued on with his plans
except through having everyone think
that he was dead the division and the
black tusk would no longer be looking
for him turning their complete attention
on each other
perhaps things were getting a little too
hot for him after his portrayal of the
black tusk and this was his contingency
plan to get the heat off his back
and the only other person that knew of
this
was theo which is why keanu was happy to
let him die at the hands of the division
from here keena may be continuing to
build his network of rogues
when you think about it we've only
really met so many so far
there are likely hundreds if not
thousands more of them out there
don't get me wrong i'm not really a fan
of the whole surprise he isn't dead idea
but i certainly wouldn't be upset if
keena comes back into the picture he was
definitely one of the more interesting
characters of the story
and this could actually help us
understand the unusual direction his
character talk at the end there
but if they do go down this path they
have to do it right because personally
and i know for a lot of others this
could break the immersion of the story
if it was done half-assed
there are a number of holes in the story
that would need to be plugged in order
to have this work
i touched on this a while ago but having
gone through it again recently i still
think it has merit and would still
probably be my preferred direction that
the story could take though certainly
not the most likely
at the end of the fellow manhunt
everything just stopped
we didn't get a cut scene there wasn't
some epic yet strangely concerning
speech from kalso or paul rhodes we
didn't even receive a notification from
isaac to say that she was deceased or
eliminated
obviously the whole ending to this
manhunt was pretty disappointing but the
sudden announcement from the division
development team that went on to explain
this manhunt was originally meant to be
the last major update to the game could
be the reason that we were left hanging
after taking down fae
i believe that there was meant to be
more to the story but because the game
was now suddenly being built on again
they changed how it was going to play
out
what if we were supposed to capture faye
similar to what we did with schaefer but
due to the apparent unexpected decision
to extend on the division over the next
year or so they potentially cut out the
final cinematic to be expanded on later
faye locates prison ellis and executes
him blaming it on the division
fey is found and taken down by the
division
following this fight a couple of comms
were revealed
these were both recordings from faye
directed at roy benitez and paul rhodes
she was apologizing for what she was
about to do
why would she even bother recording
these if she was in fact a full-blown
rogue agent defecting against the
division
what these recordings tell me is that
she has come to the conclusion that the
division is fighting a losing battle and
that the only chance they had was to
take them down from the inside
faye had become an undercover rogue
agent
faye hasn't lost hope in the government
and she still strongly believes in the
division's mission of saving what
remains
but over time watching this determined
and well-funded new enemy and the
remaining agents around her either being
killed or turning rogue joining the
black tusk ranks it was only a matter of
time before the agency fully collapsed
the only one left in the government is
corrupt and has joined the other side
the chain of command is broken
it was up to her to take him down before
he was used to bring the general
populace over to the other side
faye would go undercover and eliminate
ellis after gaining enough trust to get
close to him
she had to do this alone
firstly she didn't know who she could
trust anymore and though she could like
benitez wouldn't allow her to do this on
her own
but she had already lost enough loved
ones and didn't want to be responsible
for more of the deaths on her hands
the reason she blamed alice's death on
the division agents was to keep her
cover from being blown
after all schaefer had been captured but
she had since learned that the true
force behind the black tusk was much
bigger than originally thought
natalia sokolova was still out there and
while she is still around the threat to
the country will never disappear
yes this means that the division has now
been burned likely now to be flagged as
a rogue organization
but as there are so few of them left and
the fact that they're only losing ground
to this invading force
it was a sacrifice she had to make
plus she's likely come to the conclusion
that she can't do this alone
through doing this she may be able to
bring more of them undercover into the
btsu to help with the mission
feylau decided that it was up to her to
do what no division agent was able to
and that the only way to do this was to
go rogue and join up with the black tusk
taking down alice and the rest of its
leadership from the inside
faye had no problems with the fact that
she could die while on this mission
other than taking a chance and
eliminating the leadership i don't think
she had planned her next steps and was
forced to make some quick decisions on
the fly including the blaming of alice's
murder
and she certainly wasn't expecting to be
captured alive by the division
due to the shd now being labeled as
hostile there is the potential for a
little bit of a rift between the jtf and
the division
fey has been held in an undisclosed
location where she has been interrogated
by an understandably angry ilani calso
given kauso's generally less flexible
demeanor faye takes the beating and says
nothing
she has a plan but it involves keeping
the undercover situation on a need to
know basis
all faye says is that she wants to talk
to
benitez eventually kelso organizes a
meet-up with benitez
although he is jtf he knows faye better
than anyone else
if anyone's going to get her to talk
it's him
faye tells them everything and that this
is far bigger that they could have ever
planned for
but she isn't done and she needs his
help to finish the job
benitez believes her and on top of this
provides her with the means to escape
at this stage the btsu has no idea that
she's been captured but she couldn't
simply walk back in and join the black
tusk ranks after disappearing for so
long
she needed something that would not only
lower the chances of questions being
raised but something that would bolster
her position into the leadership
benitez further assists by providing the
location and guard schedule of
baden-schaefer
he would be a ticket back in
after breaking barton free faye rejoins
with the black tusk
although natalia sokolova is still
skeptical faye's position within the
organization has been somewhat elevated
however she is quickly put to the test
council has brought in a number of
agents to recapture faye and schaefer
she launches an assault on faye's last
known location where they once again
meet face to face
the following weeks see a number of
conflicts between faye and kelso
over time more agents are brought into
phase circle and are made aware of her
plans
but kelso is a stubbornly loyal
individual she fights for what she
believes is right
all she sees is an agent who is in a
once prominent position turning her back
on the people
the conflict continues
but now the battle is between rogue
agents fighting for different sides
in time castle would come on board with
the plan
and from here they were able to
orchestrate a number of skirmishes that
would solidify faye's position
together calso and fey would effectively
control the black tusk operations
one from the opposing side keeping up
the illusion and the other from within
their ranks
with every conflict faye gains more
trust from sokolova
she would advise kelso on opportunities
to discover intel and break convoy lines
yet faye would be able to continue
taking locations of interest for circle
over while keeping collateral damage to
a
minimum over time they would be able to
work towards bringing down natalia's
organization
including her potentially secret force
of super soldiers
the hunters
as much as i'd like to see these ideas
become the future direction of the game
we need to think about what we've seen
from the studio over the last couple of
years
they're still working on avatar and they
now have the star wars project but this
isn't to say that they don't have the
resource to work on these as well as a
division ubisoft is a huge company and
often use multiple studios to work on
games
but there has certainly been a shift in
the way that they've been handling the
franchise
like they aren't able or willing to put
in the same sort of energy this is
coming out in the way that they
communicate and market the game
it's true we're seeing an expansion of
the division universe into different
areas
but the base game has been sitting in
limbo for quite some time now
and then there was this communication
saying that they hadn't originally
planned to take the story any further
obviously i hope this will change with
the release of the new content and that
new life will be sparked into the game
but given the small amount of time in
game development terms since they
changed their minds and decided to add
more content we need to be realistic as
to what they can actually add to the
narrative direction if anything at all
i don't expect any new twists or
surprises and rather that it will
continue the current story trajectory
that we left off from
so based on this knowledge i expect that
we'll be seeing the following direction
aaron keener is dead
feylau is also dead
the shd now marked as a rogue agency may
have a few struggles to begin with but
ultimately their goal and direction
hasn't changed
under kelso's guidance the agents will
continue their fight against the black
tusk
they are now aware of natalya natalia
sokolova and her involvement in
leadership of the pmc
the following months will see the agents
learning more about her movements and
goals behind this invasion
but for now their jtf support has been
significantly reduced while they proved
themselves as more than just another
rogue agency
isaac's proven limitations have forced
the shd to reconsider the reliance on
the ai
although until changes can be made
agents are still required to utilize it
in order to keep most of their basic
functions and technology active
this could lead to several events where
agents are forced to rely on their
intuition rather than what is being
relayed through the earpiece and scantic
lenses
while all of this is happening vitaly
has finally begun work on the bioreactor
working towards the mass production of
the antivirals
the now minor factions of true suns
outcasts hyenas and even the cleaners
and ruckers will continue to play a
small part in the story as the black
tusk leadership utilized their numbers
to slow down the division
i also think we'll be seeing more of
kina's rogue agents potentially even
another group of non-kinah affiliated
rogues
i suspect we'll be hearing more about
the hunters too not just their
involvement with natalya and the black
tusk but a little more around their
origins as well
however i don't think we'll be learning
everything about them they will continue
to be shrouded in mystery
i by no means think that we'll be seeing
a wrap up of the story in any way
but the story could be at the most
resolved point that we've seen in the
last six years
[Music]
if we can just pop back to the
announcement from the dev team for the
third time in this video
it's worth noting that although they
said they originally planned to end
support this was for the division two
this isn't to say that they were
planning on stopping support for future
additions to the main game
for all we know the division 3 is well
underway but delays have meant that they
have decided to add a few more updates
to the current game
but i don't think this means we'll be
seeing the third installment any time
soon
i'd say it was still at least a couple
of years away
another thing that we need to remember
is that developer trick dempsey not so
long ago was interviewed by ign
and in this article trick clearly states
the division story is far from over
so while i may not sound overly
optimistic around the updates we'll be
seeing soon i still have faith that the
division story has a lot more in store
for us
it may just be a little further away
than we'd like
however while i play a number of other
games too particularly for a more
rounded pvp experience i still haven't
managed to find another game that even
comes close to what the division offers
as far as gameplay immersion story
weapon handling and well the list goes
on really
whatever does come out i'll be waiting
here eagerly
[Music]
hopefully you've enjoyed this video for
the most part this was just my take on
the possible directions the story could
take
while writing this i actually came up
with a number of other ways the story
could turn because to be fair it's
pretty open right now there are plenty
of options that could be worked from
let me know do you have any thoughts
around the future of the story
anyway this has ended up being a little
longer than i'd planned so i'll cut it
off here
a huge thank you to all of the channel
members that have continued to support
me even during this time of fewer
uploads it really means a lot we're
getting a bit more of a routine with the
new baby in the house so i'm hoping i'll
be able to step this up a little more
soon
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]